you know they keep saying Joe Biden's a  communist Joe Biden is a communist the  Biden Administration embracing communist  China this plan is to build back  socialists they used to say socialists  now they say communist I don't think  they know the difference but regardless  what do they mean when they say Joe  Biden's a communist that the government  is doing something that he's not just  sitting in a basement doing nothing  which they used to criticize him for now  of course they don't actually know the  definitions of Socialism or communism  but the truth is if they did they'd  realize that Joe Biden is just another  sort of boring old center-left Democrat